We have a voicemail number.
It's two one nine two David P..
Here's a very fair question about the death
rate in different states from Corona virus.
Take a listen.
Hi, David.
Short term member here, I was wondering if
you could walk me and possibly the show through
why New York State has a relatively high death
rate for moment and stapling Florida and California
have significantly lower death rates.
Are those states lying or something else going
on?
Sara, thanks.
So this is a pretty big topic and certainly
it's possible that some states are just lying.
So we don't know the real deaths per capita.
But let's assume the data are accurate, which
are that in New York, the death rate has been
about seventeen hundred per million from the
virus, whereas in Florida it's been only 500
per million.
There's a couple things to consider.
And the real answer is probably a combination
of all of these.
First of all, the places that were hit earlier
by virtue of having more direct flights to
the source areas of infection, which are China
and certain countries in Europe like New York,
got hit and overwhelmed before we understood
we were going to have to do massive social
distancing.
So the hospitals, whenever hospitals get overwhelmed
or close to it, the care suffers.
And you would expect a higher death rate.
Number two, we also now are doing a better
job of keeping the hospitals less full.
And so that is helping to keep the death rate
down in some of the later infection hotspots.
But number three, it's also a question of
timing.
If this goes on for a long time, you would
expect because remember, deaths per capita
never go down because the population at least
over it, you know, the population is relatively
fixed.
And so over time.
Time, the death rate per capita is just going
to keep going up in places in every state,
but it's going to go up faster in certain
places than others.
So it's a perfectly reasonable question.
When you get hit earlier, you're less prepared
to deal with the virus.
Also, now that there are some treatments with
some level of effectiveness, dexamethasone
as one and there are others that are considered
to be somewhat effective to different degrees,
you would expect that that would also keep
deaths down relative to the number of cases
so relatively well studied.
A fair question and a good one to understand.
Also important in thinking about how we deal
with what is expected to be a spike in the
fall as well, because states that are less
well resourced when it comes to medical resources
are going to more quickly get overwhelmed.
If we don't control the spread as the flu
season coincides with possibly a spike in
Corona virus, something important to keep
in mind on the bonus show today we will talk
about the NBA playoff boycotts.
Rella related to what's going on in Wisconsin.
We will talk about Jeff Bezos becoming the
first person ever worth 200 billion dollars.
What does it say about our economy and our
culture?
And we will also talk about Donald Trump's
insane naturalizations stunt during the first
night of the Republican National Convention.
One woman who was in the video had no idea
that she was going to be part of the Republican
National Convention.
She's not particularly pleased.
I don't think you will be shocked to hear
that people did not know they were going to
be propaganda pieces.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Become a member at join Pacman dot com to
access it instantly.